in the matter of the indictments of the
defendant Alec Murdoch for the murders
of his wife Maggie and his son Paul
the state of South Carolina rests the
prosecution has rested its case in the
murder trial of disbarred South Carolina
lawyer Alec Murdock who's accused of
killing his wife Maggie and his son Paul
at mozell their family hunting estate
the night of June 7th 2021
turn around for me I don't have anything
okay yes sir I see that okay
this is your wife and son and son okay
Murdoch has pleaded not guilty to both
murder charges over roughly four weeks
the prosecution has called on more than
50 witnesses to testify in front of the
jury and presented hundreds of pieces of
evidence the Wall Street journal's
Valerie borlein breaks down some of the
key moments we've seen so far and looks
ahead to what we can expect from the
defense
foreign isn't only facing murder charges
he's been jailed for more than a year on
99 felony counts primarily related to
allegedly swindling clients at his Law
Firm out of 8.8 million dollars over the
last decade he's pleaded not guilty to
most of the financial charges against
him the state argued we need to be able
to tell the jury what was going on in
the background as we got to June 7th how
this financial fraud that ellick had
been you know is accused of running for
a decade how it was unraveling on that
day but the defense said he's accused of
murder he this is not a trial for these
other things they shouldn't be able to
bring all that in it's prejudicial it'll
confuse the jury
judge Newman ultimately sided with the
state
so the jury then heard testimony from
Financial Witnesses including forensic
accountants and Murdoch's former
colleagues who explained how Murdoch
allegedly created a shell account to
move his money why do you call it fake
Ford because there is a real Forge
Consulting but this was a fake company
that he set up to mimic and look like
and designed to look like Forge there
was also very kind of wrenching personal
testimony including from the son of his
former housekeeper Gloria Satterfield
and so Tony Satterfield took the stand
and talked about growing up knowing elk
his whole life trusting him after his
mother died to arrange some sort of
financial settlement so the boys could
pay her medical bills they could pay the
rent on their mobile home you know and
he really trusted ellic to do that and
Elle has acknowledged taking more than
four million dollars that belonged to
those boys Murdoch signed a confession
of judgment last year admitting to the
theft
a key part of the prosecution's case
hinged on a piece of video evidence
which prosecutors say was filmed on
Paul's phone and places Murdoch at the
scene moments before the shootings
occurred and several witnesses have
taken to the stand to say they hear
Murdoch's voice in the video
it's a chicken
and one of the things the state has
tried to establish is putting very very
close friends of the family very close
friends of Paul on the stand to ask them
yes I I love Paul I love Alec and Maggie
they're a loving family well yes but
whose voice do you hear on that can you
point out Alec Murdock the person whose
voice you recognize in this video in
this courtroom please sitting right
there in a great yeah they've said I
hear ellick Maggie and Paul and it's
been devastating to see these young men
friends of Paul who clearly still have
great affection for the family
acknowledge that it's his voice that
they hear and while the prosecution has
laid out a detailed theory of what they
say happened on the night of the murders
and why the presentation of the story
was disconnected at times the state has
not really told a story kind of
beginning middle to end there have been
friends of Paul merodek on the stand and
then Financial testimony and then
ballistics evidence that has created
some sense of disjointedness in the
courtroom at times now that the state
has rested the defense will have the
chance to present its case you can
expect them to continue to try and and
poke holes in the state's case and
particularly in their process and it
just doesn't stand a reason because all
this other stuff was going on that he
would kill two people he loved very much
the defense could Echo a theory they've
previously brought up in opening
statements that a third party was
involved in the murders one shooter or
two
shotgun and an AR and by the way Maggie
has no defensive room wounds because
she's running
was she running from but one question
remains as the defense prepares its case
will Murdoch himself Testify the theory
is that you know the jury has heard
ellick lie they've heard him say and
repeatedly in sled interviews that he
did not see Maggie and Paul in the hours
before the homicide something that has
been belied by a video that shows that
he was there and so the theory is that
the only person that can address that
adequately is Alan Murdoch himself
[Music]